each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
okay I'm gonna go ahead and get started
though we people filtering in since
there's a ton of folks still out there
milling about but there the rounding
them up but I thought we may as well go
ahead and try to keep the time as much
as possible welcome to the session on
biomedical modeling are there two talks
in this session the first one today is
going to be given by Wolfgang Gila and
its is Modi B which is just enough
exchange for systems for biology data
and model do you hear me okay perfect so
I don't repeat the title in fact in the
program it's that I'm from EML but this
is the for-profit EML and I'm from the
nonprofit EML there are some some
difference and I'm presenting for a
whole bunch of people from Manchester ma
research and from stellenbosch in South
Africa sis MOS is about systems biology
of microorganisms of acid is now
single-celled microorganisms it's a
funding initiative which comprises 11
projects including 91 partners from nine
countries which started in 2007 we are
sis moody be we started in july two
thousand two thousand eight and we were
initially funded or intended to be fun
for three years which is we which we are
prolonging now we have three stuff Three
Investigators and three teams over three
sites on there's lots of three in there
the goal is to sensitively retrofit the
data access the view was they were
already some systems there and we are
the umbrella for this in order to unify
data access to this and for doing this
we have to support and manage the
diversity of data models and come
agencies and we are opting for a
web-based solution in order to exchange
data to make search possible and in
order to make dissemination of results
possible so as I said we are a whole
bunch of free people and our goal is to
put some layer in between our funding
initiative and the public and in order
to we try to put layer which is inter
project within so small which makes
publicly publishing to the outside
simpler which makes using tools from the
outside simpler and which helps people
integrate their data across sis mo
project what what did we find when we
started we found that there were own
solutions we found and still find that
there is a certain climate of suspicion
because there are when there are so many
partners it's not family anymore but
it's beyond family there are some people
within this funding initiative which are
strongly in competition and which are
asking themselves if I put my data up
there where will my personal main
competitor be able to see it a little
bit too soon or not and things like that
and their data issues there there are
sometimes with too little too dated to
work on and much of the data cannot be
compared and we are working on making
things like that comparable and there's
most of all resource issues because this
is a biology project we can go there and
say okay give me 20 people and we we
will do a nice system for you so what we
are doing is we try to go for a series
of small victories which right be
realistic we try not to reinvent the
wheel but to to reuse things as much as
possible we try to migrate to standards
make people migrate to standards and to
do something sustainable and extensible
and in order to have a system which is
going to be used
we want to have something which provides
the user some instant gratification this
is hard to do and but but this is our
goal we address doubt and anxiety by for
example having elaborate sharing
mechanisms within our system so that
people can really decide this one can't
see the data this one cannot so and we
are building it so again the the big
picture is we have several types of
people we have the experimentalists whom
we want to enable to exchange data we
have the modelers who normally also yeah
they have to type sucks check of
exchange between more or less is usually
easy to have exchanged between similar
people it's easier than having this
exchange between experimentalists and
modelers so if you look at the natural
collaboration within sis mall in a very
short simplified black-and-white way and
I don't as we say in German I don't want
to be nade to that grano Salis as
the Romans say we have collaboration
during project design because the
funding bodies say we want collaboration
between the model us and the
experimentalists so there's lots of
collaboration during the design of the
project and what happens afterwards is
that either this nice collaboration goes
on or it doesn't there are varying
methods of collaboration during projects
our requirements people they report from
their journeys into projects that they
have found a couple of by gnomes or
pairs of people working together whether
as one modeler one experimental list and
they have very close communication to
each other then we also have groups will
collaborate collaborating with groups
and this seems to work either well in
the formalized manner or sometimes less
so what we would like to give us but as
our project in what we would like to
give to people is to create some meeting
point where people automatically meet in
order to share resources and by this
further encourage better communication
so here we have a couple of I'm very
proud of this photo because it's three
types of animals sharing resources and
we would like to have this with our
three types of people I said we we have
not so many resources I like to do
simple calculations in order to to
outline this we have one software
engineer one by in fermentation and one
by a database specialist the letter to
they do a lot of modeling and
requirements analysis trying to find out
what's biologically necessary and what
needs to be programmed in our context
and we have 11 projects as I said and 91
partners so this amounts to 20
programmer days per year and per project
or in in other ways to dot 5 programmer
days per year and partner and this is
not a whole lot so we cannot afford
doing a just-in-case approach where we
say we first collect what would be nice
features to have and we program all of
them and then we are done but we really
have to make sure that we don't have a
system like word for example where most
of the people most of the features
requested are already there we no one
finds them no one uses them there are
many programs out there which I use most
of the time using just a very small
subset of features what would be our
optimum or what we are targeting is to
to just do the useful necessary features
and not doing the other ones this of
is a little bit the holy grail of
requirements engineering we try to go in
this direction by doing lots of
communication and by by helping people
help themselves so our approach to this
is a social approach we first did some
questionnaire phase which in fact was
before I came on the project and party
you see me at the first parts meeting we
didn't go drinking beer right away we
had some meeting before that but we have
these 21 postdocs and PhD students from
the from the diverse project they are
from the three types of people and they
are our design and technical
collaboration team with them we can test
ideas we can have very good open
face-to-face discussions we divided them
into two chapters from time to time we
have plenary meetings from time to time
we have chapter meetings so so that we
can see them more often at us and at a
lower cost and we do audits and sharing
so they audit what we do and they share
information about what they would like
to have done so we in way these parts
are communication means but the project
with the project so we have we are the
system ODB people on the left and we
show them what's there and they first
tell us what they think about and if
they think it's good enough they tell
their project and give the feedback back
to us
so the outcome of our first parts
meeting was very very interesting for us
we would have expected that there is a
need for something like yellow pages
that people say we want to find within
the project to else does expose it also
in the same way as I do or who uses a
given technique which I would like to
learn all things like that we were a
little bit more surprised about about
the standard operating procedures there
was a real perceived need of having one
good tool for the whole system or
consortium which administrates standard
operating procedures so that we can
really easily look up if two experiments
are comparable and but yeah our biggest
surprise at least my biggest surprise
was that everybody went like data
management we are using extra we have
heard it already in this meeting so this
change our focus a lot and I think this
amortized already all the cost we we had
with their but the power system so as I
knew I will talk after lunch i will
first feed you some images and then i
will go a little bit in in direction of
architecture and lessons lessons lot so
as we are not as we are telling
everybody with all right we have some
very nice web two dots platform where
you have you see here a yellow pages
view there are several things you can
watch in the yellow pages paper products
institutions you can change between them
easily with tabs you have a nice
bookmark area where you can drag
bookmarks into and you can easily
visually check what's what's in there we
have nice tag clouds for further search
and yeah nice system
and so this is the view for standard
operation procedures so we can see who
has uploaded the standard of operation
procedures who was the author of the
standard operation reparation procedures
and we also have thought of our modulus
the working title of this slide was
modulus delight we are enabling upload
of models into a popular model database
the the jws online database we we have
from Cisco seek from our software a
connection in which we can start
simulations out of the system we can add
studies and essays we can annotate them
they see here and we have as I said very
elaborate rights so we can have favorite
groups where we can say this I want to
share with the favorite group so and so
we can we can give other projects the
right to see data we can add or remove
individual rights for people about what
they want to see ya this is how you make
a group so this is the web up and
because XO we want to have some data
quality and there somehow the databases
side of our personality shines through
so we think we need some tooling for
people to to have high quality and excel
templates so there are people in
Manchester working on the on the excess
support in order to build templates
which
in which we can add Excel data and where
we can annotate the content of columns
by a nice pop-up menus so this was the
pr title so incremental steps from meter
to beta we try to have a nice software
which goes from working state to working
state and it's always useful so but
largely it gets a story about how to
handle XO sheets for users benefits so
the image we have is we have all these
projects many of which go like my disk
is my casa I want to be able to redirect
data when it's when it's in this system
I want to be able to retract it and I
want to be able to shut off access all
together so i think it's largely a
matter of feeling i don't think it will
happen but it's good to give people the
notion that they are taken seriously and
so the architecture is rather that this
seek platform of which I I showed you
some screenshots is at the center it
will draw in just enough metadata
information through some fabric some
layer to put on the on the different
systems just enough information so that
it becomes searchable and so that we can
then access this data and that seek
becomes a broker for this data which
still resides only on the other project
systems so again there's a need for
trade off we have huge number of
possible systems we might attach to this
there's a huge number of standards and
ontologies and and some of them are
quite big so
we can again not afford just to take all
these standards and implement them so
but we need some standardization for
search and for comparing data so what we
are doing is to move incremental e to
adjust enough standard implementation
and doing this we always think about
that we say in German devic is the sea
it's one of the rare events where German
is shorter than English so we say the
path is the goal and the translation
I've looked it up if the journey is part
of the reward which is a bit longer so
we try to have people views but what
they use anyway as far as possible and
if there are changes to be made we try
to be as unintrusive as possible we are
aware of legacy data and are the same we
match people a little bit towards best
practices and organize our actions in a
way that we give instance see instantly
useful added value to as many users as
possible so the value we want to add is
simple search simple exchange and simple
tool use including simpler workflow use
so what we have done we have provided
convincing web to 20 functionality for
use and as an appetizer I'm told that
the yellow pages for example are really
used for for for finding collaboration
partners for for quick work for asking
quick questions and the lie we have an
up load service where we can do a hand
triggered uploads of links to files of
Arts themselves where we can hand add
metadata we are currently working on a
harvesting and change detection service
for automatic download
with hand edit metadata and at the same
time we are also looking at the support
for exit templates which will promote
internal and external Senate by use and
tooling i showed the tooling a little
bit which consists of pauses snappers
and classifiers as a will show in one of
the next slides and of course where
there are other data types there are
some other data types than XL and we
will support them too so for our
architecture what we look at is that we
have some stability hierarchy what
people use gets more and more stable
when they have to agree on these things
so we have the single group or even the
single person within the single groups
who use some type of template who may be
changes them without notice but when
things get standardized across a single
system or project then they are more
stable and finally across the whole
system or project we have also to agree
on some metadata we want to pee so what
we are doing we have an architecture
where we have map us and we have passes
and annotated for project levels and we
will enter this into a more stable germ
data model so the basic architecture is
that we have the data coming from out of
the projects we have a harvest film
which casts about getting the data the
services are already knows where the
data comes from can restrict the number
of templates we have to look at when
classifying then we have a classifier
and dispatcher who recognizes templates
based on this metadata information plus
the information which is really present
in the extra file and then we have
extractor and mappa which are used in
order to get the full metadata and the
full data out of the X so this we until
quite recently intended to implement in
this fashion
that we now get vertical slices out of
this and we start to implement this but
there's some problem and this problem is
that some projects will not be prolonged
so we need first to get all the data so
we can annotate it later so what we are
doing is we are starting with the
horizontal harvester slide first slice
first and then adding the pauses
classifiers and dispatches there are
some lessons we are learning along the
way there is a need with current
standards for doing some sub setting the
standards need to be comprehensive the
goal of this sanders usually is the so
called minimum information unless the
maybe initiative some critics say it's
no no it's not minimum information its
maximum of information I don't subscribe
to that view because the standard needs
to be comprehensive but what remains is
that for a project like ours we always
will need a subset of this standard
because we have a restricted set of
experiments so for example in a single
cell something like tissue doesn't mean
anything a single cell hasn't got any
gender & and so on so what we can do
then is to do adapted subset templates
so that people don't get overwhelmed I
mean you can imagine that if you need to
annotate let's say 20 lines or so you
don't want each time to be presented
with the selection list like that and
this is one selection list coming from
such an standard ontology
we try as much as possible to to do some
some move from firefox on me to ontology
the observation is that we have a
fast-growing set of standards and that
these standards are also moving target
so once you agree that there is no no
ontology let's say for for some type of
experiments you look you look two months
later on on the on the corresponding
sides you will find out that there is in
the meantime an ontology like that but
you cannot you cannot always follow this
so what we are doing is that we are
doing an incremental approach where in
the beginning we provide keyword
annotation together with auto completion
lists we provide controlled selection
lists which our community community
created we provide where needed
home-brewed taxonomy which then can be
replaced by using standard anthologies
when they are ready and we have done to
provide migration tool a word on
software for the template tooling we are
using excellent java and sis mystique is
itself open source on the under apache
license it's built on Ruby on Rails like
my experiment Ruby on Rails is nice
because of convention over configuration
I think they're probably not so many
tough programmer software guy see we use
it Ruby on Rails is also nice because it
has many libraries and we are using some
rate specific like libraries like the
authentication for example it's simply a
library we plug into the system we we
are using solar and blue scene for the
search which introduces some a bit
unwieldy Java Ruby
see we are looking into a hole making
this mystique and easy install for later
stages because we would like people to
to get this running quickly and as a
database we are currently using my
sequel but we also test it with sequel
light so we don't introduce any database
dependencies so Stewart is quite
optimistic that he could run it on
postgres without any changes so as a
summary I talked to you about this one
to be as a virtual meeting point with
different flavors of systems biologists
our mantra is just enough just in time I
presented a flexible job extractor
extraction structure architecture talked
a little bit about just enough
incremental incrementally changed meter
data and I just say there's a lot to
done to done and still a lot to do which
is nice because we won't be out of job
too soon social the challenges ahead are
social i think the parts work really
greatly and motivated lee and now the
social challenge is to get more more
more data data data into our system and
technically there will be a couple of
big things which are rolling onto us
like publishing into public repositories
it's simply there are many of them
search and exploration will be the test
for data quality we already have some
search but we want to use in the
direction of hierarchical faceted search
or distributed by verner workflows and
things like that and for things like
that we need appropriate data quality
there will be more workflows and more
workflow functionality use usable via
this is massif software and we want to
further improve the modeling support as
a bonus
tracker bone slide what if the average
data quality is below par and what we
are thinking of is at least
experimentally is to add some nagging
functionality which reminds people of
adding or improving the emitter data so
but first we as it's just enough just in
time we want to first look if we need it
and we are not far enough to decide that
thanks a lot to all people involved the
people in fat letters are the one doing
the footwork let's say Olga from EMR
Katie and Stewart from from Manchester
special kudos to Stewart who is our
magical programming guy who who as a
lonely ride their programs all this
thanks to the funders to the BBS SCE to
the German minister Ministry of research
to the clothes jihad foundation and
finally to Microsoft for sponsoring in
this workshop which I found so far
really great so now I'm not on the spot
but in a couple of days here oh this
would be cool I've seen cab forward in
the beginning of this year yeah
the terminology between this is actually
very disparate and in some cases and
some cases actually conflicting and so
it's wondering if the reason why you
have that sub settings because you're
actually enabling all of those mappings
that is that way that the 5th ring
becomes necessary because experimental
lists normally have for example a few
methods they use they don't want to have
60 methods to choose from so I think we
can what I fear is that we give them too
many selection possibilities there will
be overwhelmed so what we are trying to
do is to as the projects are even more
specialized than the whole funding
initiative we we can do projectwise
templates which will be small enough so
this is the hope just that the
possibility of making mistakes is just
reduced this is all of it
although ontologies and things like that
if we can yes we try to do it easily
handle so i think the the big reality
check will be in a couple of months when
when we see the resulting data quality
so far we have the impression that the
that the things we give our well
accepted and now we we have to see what
comes out of it
and maybe something added to that my
group is doing a biological database a
BRK where we have lots of similar
problems like that and our observation
is that if people can add compound names
by themselves you will end up having not
a list wishes as impressive as the
different spellings of Britney Spears at
Google but which which where we have
three or four spelling mistakes and
things like that so we have the
impression that for many things we have
to have at least the controlled
vocabulary state